vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mes petits amis beau soir
patron mais bien sûr mon gros nounours
descend vite leur montrer ton beau livre
moi je le raconterai la suite des
aventures de notre petite amie
cornichons ou le genre homo pop ou
cornichons se trouvent toujours chez le
gros bûcheron qui est très gentil avec
lui quand nichons lui s'occupe de
juliette à le hibou mais juliette a
n'est pas toujours très sage je peux
continuer de raconter mon histoire le
nours résume pas trop nous sommes
preuves mais pas trop le gros bûcherons
et le petits cornichons sont en train de
charger dans une grande charrette le
bois qu'ils ont coupé et ramasser pour
aller le vendre au village travail et
cornichons être courageux mais tout à
coup ils entendent des cris perçants
décrit de lapin quoi quelques rides du
poulain au oui
cette coquine de julietta pour s'amuser
est en train d'essayer d'attraper un
mignon petit lapin la vienne pourquoi
faut bien que ça me nicole à l'on
retourne à la maison juliette a tué
méchante lui dit cornichons juliette à
s'en va et le joli petit lapin qui n'a
plus peur continue de creuser son
terrier qu'est ce que c'est
un terrier un trou dans la terre dans
lequel les lapins installent leurs
bureaux il gratte avec ses deux pattes
et il fait rouler des cailloux sur les
pieds de cornichons il gratte une gratte
du ch vous jugeront regarde corniche on
ramasse plusieurs cailloux qui sont très
beaux mais ce sont des agates et celle
ci est encore plus belle
c'est une améthyste et notre bûcheron
lui montre une pierre
la plus belle que cornichons et jamais
vu elle est de la couleur des yeux de
maman et cornichons suivi par son ami
retourne dans la cabane maman elle est
une bonne dynamique dit ce témoin j'ai
une bio magath
le petit garçon mais les agat dans sa
bouteille avec les perdre les
coquillages la pièce en or et la pierre
de lune aux couleurs changeantes qu'il
garde pour sa maman
faudrait quand même qu'il la retrouve sa
maman tient lui dit le bûcheron et il
laisse tomber l'améthyste précieuse dans
la bouteille
tu la retrouves râteau moment je te le
promets qui quand est-ce qu'ils la
retrouvent new york
la prochaine fois les enfants vous
verrez allons les enfants l'histoire est
finie
nous allons nous coucher tout de suite
le neuf ce qu'ils sont gentils
nous sommes condamnés à nous
bonne nuit les petits la jette à la
lumière at home
[Applaudissements]
alors les enfants l'histoire vous a plu
oui eh bien allez vite vous coucher on
n'y va pas trop en route mon cher
nounours bah de nuit fait pour
oh
e
[Musique]
oh
or